يسترجع اللاعب الدولي السابق رياض جلاس
هدفه الحاسمه ضد ليبيريا ايام النجم
جورجيا والذي فتح به لتونس الطريقه للترشح
لمونديال
ان مجموعه تونس في مونديال قطر هي الاصعب
بين منتخبات العرب انا من نجمش نحكي على
كاليفيكاسيون
نعمله ماتشوات ممتازه خاصه ممكن نعرف هناك
تكتيكيا معناها المدرب
قطر
سينما يثق في قدره المنتخب على اجتياز
الدور الاول بكثير من التفاؤل
قلتها في مقدور المنتخب الاولى
في حد ذاته وانت صقر من جهه اخرى وهناك من
الجماهير من حاول ان يكون عقلانيا في
التعبير عن امل الترشح للدوره الثانيه
ان شاء الله نكون نحن نكون ما نفهمه
مشكوره وجينا القادمه
قد تؤتي اكلها امام قوه المنافسين المهم
تبدو صعبه صحيح لكن في كره القدم
لكن احنا زاد عنها وهي تكتيكيه منتخب
الدفاعي خمسه لاعبين محور الدفاع في
التشكيله الموسعه واكثر من سبعه وسط
الميدان دفاعي لكن كره القدم العصريه تعود
البرشا هذا اللاعب الدفاع المنتخب 2014
النهائي كاس العالم بتشكيله الدفاعيه الكل
اجمعه في تونس ان الصعوبه النسور قد يخفف
منها عامل الارض العربيه ولهيب الجماهير
التونسيه في مونديال قطر 2022